these are some of the real drugs were
tested in a lab on the outskirts of
Oxford the drug hunters are taking on
Kovac 19 with the help of artificial
intelligence they're scanning a back
catalogue of 12,000 chemical compounds
for possible activity against the virus
the results are instant a deep blue a
signal of a possible match the drugs
have already been investigated for other
diseases and past initial safety studies
repurposed for the corona virus
scientists will be able to skip forward
two trials in patients in a matter of
months there's a lot to learn and the
fastest we can target different protein
and try which one is the right one which
one we need to target to develop
treatment against kovat 19 to better
hospital trials of existing antiviral
treatments in coronavirus patients have
so far proved disappointing but the
Accenture scientists are confident that
a drug designed for a completely
unrelated disease might by chance have
the right structure to also stop the
corona virus in its tracks the
scientists here are hoping to find a
drug that hits the corona virus where
its most vulnerable that might be the
protein it needs to get inside cells or
it could be the proteins it needs to
make copies of itself if they find a
good match it could prevent the
catastrophic damage being done inside
patients lungs the drug Hunt is being
accelerated by Britain's most powerful
microscope a loop more than three times
the size at Wembley Stadium that
generates a beam of light ten billion
times brighter than the Sun it allows
scientists to see individual atoms but
the drug highlighted in color locking
onto the virus it should be possible to
design the perfect match and stop the
virus in its tracks they call it The
Cove admonish at here we have a view of
one of the components of the virus that
is
active site where it does the actual
work and what we are trying to do in all
drug discovery projects but is to find a
compound that we can stick in there and
essentially block it from doing its
reactions dunking up the words it used
to take a decade to develop a new
medicine but the urgency of the pandemic
and the lack of a vaccine is driving
innovation and could result in effective
treatment faster than ever before Thomas
More Sky News